Oh
well it's me again thanks to all you
wonderful people two days ago I was able
to upload a 10,000 subscriber thank you
video
now here we are sitting at over fifty
thousand with this huge boost in new
viewers I'm finally able to start
considering making YouTube my full-time
occupation it won't be easy but I'm sure
that with the help of the amazing second
thought family we can make it a reality
a few people have already reached out to
me asking how they can donate to help
fund new videos and that's why I'm here
today
I'm officially launching a patreon page
for second thought your support on
patreon will help me devote more time to
making videos and hopefully allow me to
upload more often making these videos is
very time consuming and unfortunately
YouTube ad revenue doesn't quite cover
the time I spend making them that's
where you come in check out the patron
rewards for each donation amount on my
page at patreon.com slash second thought
thank you all so much for your continued
support
[Music]